romanow vous avez gagné votre promo
avant qu'on appelle un restaurant parce
que je vous le dis c'est l'anniversaire
de nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui nicolas
sarkozy
il est né le 28 janvier 1955 donc je
vais essayer de faire une imitation ils
ne savent pas c'est que nicolas sarkozy
allait auprès d'un grec
voilà le dire qu'on va mener moi je suis
sortie au restaurant le but regarder il
y à regarder des gens qui sont dehors
voilà regarder sur direct 8 on dirait qu
ils vont aller faire la promo très
couture et les remercier de ce genre
pour faire la promo pour votre spectacle
anne roumanoff tout va bien voilà merci
danuri que je connais déjà plein de gens
que je connais je vous donnerai droite
soit ils vont aller faire la promo pour
vous on les retrouvera contre
démissionner d'accord comme ça ça me
fait plaisir ses pairs et ben voilà elle
a gagné sa promo c'est parti si j'arrive
à rester une minute avec eux je vous le
dis je fais gagner un cadeau pour tout
le public
c'est quoi le reste on sait qu'on
l'attend c'est quoi le restaurant balle
est récente allô allô allô oui allô oui
oui bonjour je suis bien au s'offre à
l'eau propre
oui vous m'entendez monsieur à l'eau est
ce qu'on peut avoir un coup de fil
correct techniquement on épand ton ça
veut dire mine de rien ici il m'a dit
non on fait qui veut gagner des millions
l'appel à un ami on peut pas leur en a
plein d'amis mais juste comme ça du
balcon stop alors jeté la question sinon
moi j'ai une idée à parce que j'ai
réussi pendant un pub à peut-être je
sais pas si c'est le bon me procurer le
numéro de nicolas sarkozy alors est ce
qu'on appellerait pas nicolas sarkozy
directement
je vais le tenter on sait qui c'est un
les mecs ils ont mis la tombe d'ailleurs
au cas où il a gaffé qui est le gala
soba donc on va la perdre je sais pas du
tout c'est le bon numéro
ce que j'ai demandé un gars on va voir
si c'est possible je l'appelle
directement
non mais c'est peu si c'est lui c'est
une dar k c'est une bonne d'arcari oui
allô allô allô nicolas sarkozy c'est
cyril est requis c'est cyril hanouna
cyril hanouna ça va bien oui ça va bien
alors on est en direct dans touche pas à
mon poste et je sais que c'est votre
anniversaire c'est juste pour vous
souhaiter bon anniversaire
non mais je mets juste on vous dit bonne
anniversaire voilà ce que le public peut
dire bon anniversaire
enfin bijoux enfin gros bisous je vous
envoie le cadeau une table de ping pong
je vous embrasse très fort merci au
revoir merci au revoir
il a kiffé ans il a quitté
bon bah ça c'est fait
il ay la veille sur moi ce serait très
bon job une table de ping pong et non
bis in aller après nicolas sarkozy a
bien réagi à la bière et la dar k et
ensuite après quand il voit qu'il est en
public il dit attention je ne peux pas
et vient sur sur petacchi
[Rires]